[Música]
y
bueno hola a todos os preguntaréis qué
hago yo aquí hoy he venido a contar una
historia de desobediencia y de humildad
o sobre todo una historia en la que los
sueños se cumplen cuando todos estamos
conectados
empecé en este deporte cuando tenía 3
años porque mi familia siempre ha estado
relacionada con el mundo de la moto mi
padre es mecánico y estuvo trabajando en
la competición con otros pilotos antes
de que yo naciera la primera moto que
llego a casa fue para mi hermano mayor
un poco después llegó otra para mí hubo
un tiempo en el que las dos entrenamos
juntas pero bueno ella luego decidió que
no era lo suyo así que me tocó seguir a
mi sola siempre fui muy competitiva
tanto en el deporte como en la vida y
bueno aunque os parezca difícil con
cuatro años convencí a mis padres de que
me dejaran hacer mi primera carrera
a partir de ese momento todo fue como
como una rueda mis padres me llevaban a
entrenar cada fin de semana y a mí me
encantaba me montaba en moto que era lo
que más me gustaba hacer y además tenía
un montón de compañeros con los que
jugar así que era el plan perfecto a
partir de ahí fui creciendo pasando por
un montón de categorías un montón de
campeonato y bueno me encontré con la
condición de que el motociclismo siempre
ha sido un deporte mayoritariamente
masculino así que bueno era la única o
de las pocas mujeres que lo practicaba
moss aún así siempre fui un piloto muy
rápido muy competitiva y luche
prácticamente por ganar todos los
campeonatos en los que competir
el cambio más grande de mi carrera
deportiva se produjo a los 14 años hasta
entonces simplemente practicaba este
deporte porque me divertía a partir de
ese momento me dieron la oportunidad de
dar el salto al campeonato de españa
este campeonato el campeonato con más
nivel antes del mundial así que llegué
allí dejé de ir a competir con mi
familia para pasar a formar parte de un
equipo profesional tenía un montón de
gente trabajando para mí y no sabía muy
bien qué hacer con todo aquello era muy
joven y tenía que adaptarme a muchísimas
cosas en muchísimos cambios que bueno me
tendrían que ayudar a formarme y para
algún día llegar a ser profesional
estuve durante durante dos temporadas
allí en ese tiempo me convertí en la
primera mujer de la historia en puntuar
en la categoría y poco después me dieron
la oportunidad de dar el salto al
campeonato del mundo de moto 3a y bueno
mi primera carrera fue en qatar era la
primera vez que salía de españa a
competir y para mí llegar allí ya era un
éxito había conseguido un uno de los
sueños de mi vida llegar a ser piloto
profesional y estar en una parrilla de
motogp
así que hasta ahí todo bien
durante esa temporada supere todas las
expectativas tanto las mías como las de
la gente que tenía alrededor me convertí
en la primera mujer española de la
historia en puntuar en el campeonato en
la mejor posición de una mujer en
parrilla de salida con una séptima
posición en australia y el mejor
resultado en carrera con una octava
posición en valencia así que hasta ahí
todo perfecto en un año increíble y
todos felices a partir de ahí había
conseguido todo lo que siempre había
querido tener pero al acabar la
temporada y a pesar de que la última
carrera consigue el mejor resultado de
mi vida me encontré con los verdaderos
problemas
no tenía patrocinadores así que eso
significaba que no tenía equipo no tenía
mucho para continuar el año siguiente y
que el sueño se terminado ahí
siempre fui un poco cabezota así que
lejos de rendirme y a pesar de que tenía
16 años y mucho por aprender
mi única obsesión era encontrar un
equipo encontrar una moto y seguir
trabajando para conseguir mi sueño tuve
que llamar a muchísimas puertas a hablar
con muchísima gente y tener que
enfrentar enfrentarme a un montón de nov
pero al final lo conseguí
la temporada 2014 volví a seguir en el
campeonato del mundo otro año más pero
empezó un poco el declive de mi carga
deportiva la falta de medios me hizo
estar en un equipo y una moto un poco
competitivo así que bueno fue un año de
mucho aprender de madurar mucho porque
me di cuenta de que por mucho que
trabajes y no tienes los medios nunca
vas a conseguir tu objetivo así que
la frustración con la que competía ese
año fue fue muchísimo tenía que soportar
muchísima presión y bueno a falta de
cuatro carreras el equipo me comunicó
que no podía acabar la temporada por
falta de presupuesto así que me fui a
casa
al año siguiente y gracias a los
resultados que me hablaban de la
temporada anterior volví a encontrar
otro equipo volvía a ser piloto del
campeonato del mundo pero bueno a pesar
de que de que trabajé muchísimo tenía
tenía muchísima ilusión muchas ganas me
he esforzado mucho para llegar al cien
por cien al inicio de la temporada otra
vez me encontré con un amigo una moto
poco competitiva
esta imagen es un poco feo pero la
quería enseñar porque creo que la imagen
del quiero y no puedo
a pesar de que de que me había esforzado
mucho en tener una moto poco competitiva
me obligó a tener que sobrepasar el
límite muchas veces tener que arriesgar
más de la cuenta y bueno tuve varias
lesiones durante la temporada antes de
empezar una fractura de la clavícula y
prácticamente tres o cuatro meses
después tuve esta caída fue en la
carrera de alemania y bueno yo haya
bajado sola en mi familia estaba en casa
y bueno los médicos detectaron que tenía
una fractura en el húmero así que volé a
barcelona llegué con la esperanza de que
la lesión fuera lo más pequeña posible y
poder volver pronto a competir pero allí
me encontré con un médico que me decía
que la lesión era bastante grave que
tenía que pasar por quirófano y que
necesitaríamos seis meses de
recuperación
seis meses no parece tanto pero seis
meses significaba que mi temporada se
había terminado allí
así que me operé volví a casa y empecé a
trabajar me pasaba los días enteros en
rehabilitación con el único objetivo de
poder volver antes del final del
temporada
al mes y medio llamé al mail y le dije
mira me voy a competir yo creo que estoy
preparada que así que voy a un
vuelo a inglaterra y lo voy a intentar
así que eso hice volem llegué en la
tierra y a partir de ese momento hice
las ocho carreras que quedaban de la
temporada y me tocó sufrir mucho mucho
dolor muchas molestias pero
por lo menos pude cumplir mi objetivo
que era volver a subirme encima de la
moto y buscar el tener una buena
oportunidad si a la falta de medio le
sumamos que en mis condiciones físicas
no eran las más adecuadas pues está
claro que los resultados tampoco
salieron así que a final de temporada
tuve que abandonar el campeonato del
mundo
ese fue el momento más duro de mi vida
el palo más grande que he llevado porque
llevaba toda mi vida trabajando para ser
piloto y un momento a otro todo lo que
había construido ese se derrumbó me
quedé fuera del campeonato me quedé sin
equipo sin moto sin patrocinadores y sin
posibilidades de poder seguir luchando
por conseguir mi sueño
pero he tenido la suerte de que mi
familia siempre me ha apoyado mucho
desde el inicio de encontrarme a lo
largo de toda mi carrera a mucha gente
que ya ha creído en mí y me ayudaba a
salir de momentos tan tan duros como
como ese a superar
a aquella situación a pesar de que era
tan joven que no conseguía entenderlo
y bueno estuve durante todo el año dando
un poco de tumbos intentando competir en
diferentes sitios para mantenerme activa
y esperar que llegara una oportunidad y
así lo hice a finales del año 2016
empecé a recibir llamadas y se abrió un
nuevo un nuevo camino una nueva
oportunidad esta vez en el campeonato
del mundo de superbike y bueno empecé a
formar parte de una escuela de mecánico
allí la falta de experiencia era lo que
más teníamos pero creo que la ilusión la
gana y la unión por la que trabajamos
todos juntos nos dio la oportunidad de
ganar y conseguir la victoria en la
carrera de portugal me fue la primera
mujer de la historia en ganar una
carrera en el campeonato del mundo y a
partir de ese momento fue un poco el
antes y el después de mi carrera
deportiva
creo que mucha gente se dio cuenta de
que lo que yo decía de que una mujer es
voy a ganar en un mundo de hombres era
posible y así que a partir de este
momento empecé a contar con muchísimo
más apoyo
encontré a la gente adecuada en el
momento justo que me dio la oportunidad
de seguir creciendo de seguir contando
con un material mejor para el año
siguiente empecé a contar con el apoyo
de la fábrica de kawasaki y así afronte
empecé a trabajar para afrontar la
temporada 2018 este año
ha sido el mejor año de mi carrera
deportiva a pesar de todo lo que hemos
tenido que pasar este año he vivido una
temporada de ensueño
este es mi equipo de este año hemos
trabajado muchísimo hemos intentado
remar todos en la misma dirección que
creo que es lo más importante para
llegar a buen puerto
desde el inicio fuimos muy competitivos
empecé a liderar el campeonato en la
tercera carrera tuve dos victorias
seguidas en italia inglaterra y a pesar
de que bueno hemos sufrido momentos muy
difíciles a lo largo de la temporada
llegamos a la última carrera con
opciones de ganar el campeonato
la última carrera fue en francia hace
prácticamente muy poco y bueno fue muy
estresante aquello llegamos
prácticamente hasta la última curva sin
saber si habíamos ganado
al pasar por meta de hecho ni ni sabía
que lo había conseguido
y poco después me enteré
la charla la quería terminar con con
esta imagen esta mujer es mi madre pero
creo que representa muy bien el que la
unión hace la fuerza'
hemos trabajado toda la vida para
conseguir este sueño y creo que junto
con mi equipo los patrocinadores las
fábricas toda la gente que en algún
momento de mi vida me ha ayudado a poder
ir construyendo este camino que a pesar
de que en algún momento lo veíamos que
era el final hemos intentado buscar
caminos alternativos para llegar a
conseguir mi sueño
esta foto desde el día que me proclamé
campeón del mundo
he sido la primera mujer de la historia
en ganar un campeonato del mundo de
velocidad y creo que representa todos
los valores que los que hay que luchar
no me voy a entretener mucho más creo
que hay mucha gente que se quiere hablar
pero quiero que de todo lo que he dicho
final en mi historia y tampoco la vaya a
recordar mucho tiempo quiero que os
quedéis con tres cosas la primera es que
es muy importante saber con qué medios
contamos y hasta dónde podemos llegar
con ellos
lo segundo que hay que confiar en los
nuestros intentar rodearnos de gente que
nos ayude a ser cada día mejores siempre
utilizo la misma frase si camina solo
irá muy rápido pero si también
acompañado llegarán más lejos así que yo
he conseguido ser campeona porque hay
mucha gente que está aquí hoy estoy
dando la cara yo pero el sueño es de
todos y creo que el objetivo y el
haberlo conseguido es gracias a toda la
gente que bueno ha puesto su granito de
arena en en este camino y la tercera y
la más importante es que no hay que
tirar la toalla en la clave de mi vida y
de mi carrera deportiva a pesar de que
tengo 21 años solamente ha sido el no
tirar la toalla el seguir trabajando
aunque viera que las cosas se estaban
poniendo muy difíciles que prácticamente
he visto que mi sueño se acababa en
muchísimas ocasiones pero creo que hay
que creer en uno mismo creer que todo es
posible
el último consejo es que con trabajo los
sueños se cumplen así que espero que
todos vosotros también podéis cumplir el
vuestro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ya no
[Música]
[Aplausos]